you start yeah let's start now oh man
come in hot i'm sweating mark
but we're not gonna hear that part are
we good to see you guys
i know i did it's tough appreciate you
guys doing the show man
we got mark sanchez and scotty mcknight
in the house
why did you do it like that i always
like to talk to the mic like this
because i'm going to think about where
we're going to go with the show you know
because there's a lot to unfold with
both of you for the viewers
you're mark sanchez so you're good
with scotty with scotty mcknight meets
got to go way back both played at unc
colorado
scotty is a hall of famer i think that's
fair to say
not yet but that'd be cool is there a
hall of fame i don't know if there is
a ring of buff on her is there like
there's a ring above is there a ring
and you're not in it i'm not in it i'm
not
do you think it's because you're a white
receiver i don't think so
um although nelson spruce did
come in and break my records a few years
after oh he was a stud
he was really good did he get drafted he
i think he went
here he was in the seventh round or he
went undrafted and then he
he played really well in preseason for
the rams
yeah and he became like a fan favorite
and then i think he got hurt
and he's kind of bounced around a little
bit who was theirs and he played at xfl
xfl he did really well that's about like
13 catches in the game also a bummer
um that's not fun i play an arena i
don't talk about it
hey you did i did utah blaze shout out
to the blaze
no way yeah and then they're like hey
man is there any way you can get to 300
pounds
like wait what and i was going i'm gonna
go home now i'm gonna go home
i don't wanna be 300 pounds i'm gonna go
home it's an odd name choice for a utah
team
you saw blaze no one was blazing
anything else at all yeah right
yeah it was the dark days i brought you
guys on because nfl football season
kicks off thursday
correct how crunk are you two for it
finally i mean you're a espn analyst
so were you worried that the season
because a lot of it like
if you listen to like clay travis like
there's a lot of analysts out there like
yeah football's happening man football's
[ __ ] happening
and then all the corona bros like no
it's not there's no way it's impossible
obviously it's happening now i'll see
the pac-12's a giant bunch of [ __ ]
and the big ten giant [ __ ]
but other than that college football is
fully back sec is crushing it
they're going to nfl is back so were you
worried that kind of
because with what you do it's important
right oh no you're gonna just
be sitting around there's nothing or you
just you know
uh talk about hopefully when football
comes back and it gets really boring
and predicting and why people made
certain decisions but
for the nfl
one they own a day of the week right
sunday is theirs
i would say sunday monday right kind of
two right and thursday
thursdays thursday's okay three nights
of the week yeah
but for sure sunday right it's no
chick-fil-a you go to church and you
watch football it's kind of what happens
right so they approach the situation
how do we play football we understand
what's going on we understand the risk
how do we eliminate risk and how do we
play football where the pac-12
and big ten approached it like chaos
maybe we're not playing and then we
can't and you don't have to decide right
now like no we're not playing like right
oh
hold on you don't have literally you
don't you have you have months to decide
you don't have to cancel now though nope
we're out and then scc went well no
we're actually they took the nfl stance
they're not so big on the big ten too
like the commissioner was like we're not
playing
yeah and then big ten you know in
football doesn't get any bigger ohio
state's like
oh no we want to play justin fields yeah
yeah justin fields was
huge in so trevor lawrence the activism
basically telling guys like yo we want
to play and now if you only have the big
12 if you only have
the sec and you only have the acc which
now has notre dame
to make them a little more legit right
so clemson doesn't just roll through
hopefully they play them in the
championship that's the play uh but
now there's an asterisk if ohio state's
not involved in this college football
playoff
because they were almost a shoe-in for
the playoff before the season started
and before the big ten camps don't you
think they're gonna feel like dumbasses
the big ten gentlemen
this is what bothers me is with the
pac-12
i guess just we have too much [ __ ] going
on here on the west coast nobody cares
there's been no fight
like no sc was like yeah we're fine with
it well like nobody cares
i think there's a reason behind that i
think the big political oh
i think if you look at it the big ten
right now is is revisiting if they're
going to have a season maybe they're
going to they're talking about starting
in november
the pac-12 they're gonna have a season
the pac-12 is not revisiting it
and if you look at just the landscape of
what players were organizing the most
and were the most outspoken it was the
pac-12 players led by some guys at
stanford
and they were demanding i think did you
read their demands
fifty percent of tv come on fellas
listen if you get so what they're saying
give me 100 yards you're not going to
get 100. but if we land at 80
they're trying to shoot for the moonland
on the stars but if you look at the
demands like all right well
here's just first of all and i they i
think players should be paid
but what their demands what they're
asked for you realize if they gave you
50 of the revenue
there would be no other sports so your
sports cover everybody else oh yeah they
play so nobody so football so your
girlfriend that plays for the volleyball
team she wouldn't have a team to plant
yeah basketball team they're not around
i think we're headed there oh really you
think they cancel sports
not sports so i think that they're gonna
have to take a hard look at and part of
this is based on coronavirus they're
going to have to take a hard look at
the current landscape and where it's
headed because it's going to change the
players understand their power
well exactly corona has given them the
time
to figure out i think the time but then
also it's like
you see these universities especially
these major universities where it's like
oh no we'll play two seasons we're going
to go back to back and players like hold
up wait what are the players in the
spring that we're going to the nfl
they're
like you know blue chip players are like
it's nuts and you realize they're doing
it because they need the money and the
player's like oh
oh that's why we're oh no no we want
money yeah that's what we know but
[ __ ]
that's why the pac-12 and the big ten
said no right away they knew
the fight they had on their hands with
the players i'm telling you corona
and i don't want to put this lightly
there is a pandemic people are dying i'm
not saying that it's not a real virus
that's not what i'm saying
i'm just saying i'm just not as big of a
risk
as other groups right that's not the
target group that's just
dropping right not nothing so right so
the problem is that that wasn't more or
less of an easy out
for these conferences to say no football
we don't want to deal with it right now
but really they're saying
oh crap what are we going to do about
these player demands
because yeah corona is our excuse right
now
but next year if they have the same set
of demands the players can
walk anyway and now think how much money
they're going to lose once in a row
i mean that's so i said this on espn i
was like
and did you get in trouble uh no i don't
think they whip you when you got off
no no no they they're you're allowed to
have your opinions and i respect that
uh there and they respect my opinions
but it's not a popular one and it's not
like people are like whoa like but i
didn't even think about it because of
covid well
yeah that's part of it but to me like
it's deeper big big ten
and backpack 12 well i look at to me it
it's political the reason i'm not
playing
because a lot of it's blue states well
it's four teams in california weren't
going to be able to practice they
couldn't have hold practices so
that's a quarter of their league in the
pac-12 but
think about this in ohio so ohio state
can't play which is the third of their
league
it's poor math yeah it's already good
okay no one's gonna you want to buy real
estate for me yeah right
so but in ohio so you're gonna have the
cleveland browns play
yeah you're gonna have cincinnati play
oh yeah you're gonna not ohio state ohio
play
the bobcats but not ohio state crazy how
insane that is
how about in pennsylvania you have the
eagles you have the [ __ ] you know
pittsburgh steelers but you're not going
to have penn state yeah that's wild
well how about thursday night kansas
city houston there should be forty four
thousand fans
oh i didn't know that oh yeah oh yeah
papa there's forty four thousand people
can't so they're in missouri then yeah
on the kansas side well missouri
yeah wow they're about forty four
thousand fans something like that
but the capacity is like seven they're
gonna spread yeah i'm sure but
the arrowhead or what happens if what
happened but how weird is it like it's
to me it's so confusing if well
because if you're the pac-12 and you're
watching like how are you the big
big 10 you're like how were we not
playing
well they just had who oregon just had
pinay sewell who's
potentially the number one overall pick
the lineman yeah
offensive tackle stud just opted out
because like
look they're not gonna play a season so
what's the bigger conversation what
we've been talking about is like
now these players headed into their
third year that like
by rule have to play three full seasons
before their nfl
do they just if you've proven yourself
your freshman and your sophomore year
do you traditionally do you just give up
a hundred percent because now the third
year and start training well 100 because
now the nfl can't hold it against you
when before they're like oh he doesn't
love football well you know
like three holy baby you have to be
three years removed yes
you don't have to actually playing cards
just three years just three years
seriously
so they're good but but originally if
you were a guy who was gonna be the
first pick and you want to sit on a
season they'd like go
red flag because he doesn't want to play
he doesn't really want to get hurt
anymore he's
7 million penn state is the top
defensive player potentially in the
draft you have penney sewell
uh jamar chase just left ellis in
training camp like
practicing for the season coming up and
he's three weeks before yeah
yeah but what do they have to gain right
nothing everything is
such a weird thing going on man
especially if you same thing if you win
this national championship you make this
playoff it's like with an asterisk
because
so many teams didn't play it's an hour
some major teams didn't play
yeah maybe not from the pac-12 but from
the big ten pac-12 who who would compete
for that honestly
of course i went there so i want them to
do well they would have been okay
they would have made a little run they
had a favorable schedule other than
alabama
week one alabama would have that would
have been rough and sarc's the offensive
coordinator after leaving sc
like there's a little bad blood let's be
real it's not like anyone's like gosh
no they wouldn't be here they wouldn't
have been colorado
colorado i heard undefeated national
championship
it was going to be our year it was our
year it was our [ __ ] year dude
so there's gonna be an asterisk exactly
but there as far as national i don't
know if there's naturally to me like the
team's playing it's like
what a bunch of badasses like how about
byu or how about navy like
you look at byu their entire season
every team canceled and they went man
we're still going to play
and they came up with a makeshift
schedule and they're continuing to play
yeah why not so it's like i it to me
it's like it's almost
you know just almost kicking it to the
man these teams playing like the sec
just stood by i was like now we're going
to play man because well nebraska was
talking about trying to join the acc
i loved it and they got crapped on by
everybody
i mean completely just crapped on by
everybody in the network
right yeah yeah he was like no we're
playing and then
well then a lawyer was like listen we
love the idea we love it
we have a contract with these people so
we can't just jump ship dude yeah
well here's the interesting thing too so
who was we were talking to someone the
other day about this and they said
what is stopping uh michigan from
playing
ohio state on pay-per-view no one
well would have to there has to be i
don't again i'm not a tv contract
that's i'm saying there has to be some
but but those contracts are avoided
right those contracts are voided because
so you could argue either side yeah
right now especially
because like everything dude but you
should get a house take your argument
every saturday and charge
99 and they'd have a hefty payday
i would pay every every everybody would
the players play unless they're not
getting paid if they're not getting paid
oh yeah don't you think maybe they're
not really good i mean
let's give them some of the paperwork if
it was like sc ucla and i'm a senior and
i was supposed to play
like or maybe a junior like this is
going to be my first year starting kind
of thing i'd be like
i'd get in like three of those games
hell yeah maybe not all 10.
three i'm in three it's yeah there might
be an actually to me it's almost like a
like whoever wins is just a bunch of
badasses man you dealt with
all this [ __ ] and you still figure
out a way to play
the scc one for me one from you yeah
right
but you look at the sec it's like you
know and i'm never i'm not a big sec fan
but it is the best conference
i still think there's an argument that
bottom of the barrel
sec is comparable to oh bottom bill is
awful
yeah it's comparable to some other yeah
but um who cares about bottom bill i
know
yeah who puts out the most tennessee
closer to i mean like cal went out and
whooped up on ole miss
at like nine in the morning their time
last year
like you know there's pac-12 no i'm just
saying there's
games in there and there's competition
in there that's closer than people think
i still think the scc edges everybody
out but it's closer than people think
no i agree well also sometimes sec is
just boring
yeah a little bit until ellis you know
tell us you came along with that high
power
offense that was just fun to watch that
was fun uh
going to the nfl you think trevor
lawrence or i guess not trevor launch
but we'll go with your boy uh
burro you think he's the real deal
time cause you guys you guys study those
guys right we do hard
it's just before you answer here's
what's interesting for the fans out
there
uh burro before this year they projected
maybe a late round pick maybe free agent
but like the sixth or seventh round pick
people liking him some of his own
coaches internally likened him to
josh mccown who was a career backup guy
journeyman kind of a great job by the
way
great job yeah and played really well
that's no slight on
on joshua county then he's the awesome
player then he has one of the best op
seasons of all time of all time and now
he's
the best quarterback to ever be drafted
is it a system thing or is it a
match-up thing i think a lot of things
came
to fruition at the right time it was
like this perfect storm in some ways
where
you rank him against two uh jordan love
um who else won the first justin herbert
he doesn't have a stronger arm than any
of them
he's not more athletic than any of them
he had a way better team than all of
them this team was stacked
unbelievable that he gets better but
those three wide receivers chase
jefferson
marshall marshall i don't know if you're
ever going to have yeah and thaddeus
monster tight end
and clyde edwards running back i don't
know if you're ever going to have
a squad like that that was almost like
when uh when it was like tony gonzalez
roddy white
uh julio jones matt ryan like when they
had
when do you get that that they left and
matt ryan's right but when do you get
that in the nfl it's so hard
yeah uh he doesn't have a mentality
though he really does
he's a cocky guy oh dude which i like a
good way yeah
yeah not where it's like over the top
about like mayweather but
correct me wrong but i think when you
look on on like
film two is the freak too besides
blowing out his goddamn hip he's afraid
so freaky is he that freaky oh dude he's
just he's
so instinctual wait the way sarkeesian
said it and scotty heard him he was just
like
he does stuff on film that amazes you
because he's there's twitchy athletes
and you're like wow how did that guy
physically make that play but he's like
he went through this read so quickly and
his body's already reacting to something
that he processed so fast that's the nfl
he's like that translates so well to
this next level because you have to do
that
now can you guarantee success well he's
got to stay healthy he's got to be in
the right system
and then all those things should happen
but it's same thing with burro was this
a perfect storm was it a good team
or is boro the answer so it's a
combination of both it's just you gotta
cultivate that atmosphere for them or
it's about also they're
like to us at miami not a great
atmosphere
burrows at cincinnati not a great
atmosphere so that makes it tough
but then also with your boy tua
you know they just cut uh rosen right
josh rosen so now they only have one
quarterback yeah so fitz is ahead of him
fitzpatrick is ahead of them
fitz is 74 years old is that right
75 next week 75 years he's he's they
named him the starter
right their offensive line ain't going
to win any awards so it's like how long
is he going to stay healthy
yeah and then you're getting questions
they did they did boost their team they
they did well in the draft they took
austin jackson out of the usc
uh they took the other kid robert uh
hunt i think out of louisiana lafayette
yeah
tackle or big offensive guard so they
beefed up protection for him but
it's gonna take some time this isn't a
plug-and-play kind of year with them
like with two
not like tampa right oh my god it's just
a difference
it's just a different animal we're going
what i did see with tua is because we
shot this documentary with them so i
lived on the road with tua for like six
months
nice kid great kid great kid he's he's
he's super religious
he's he's religious uh he's like yeah
it's to me god he comes off as like in
your face religious right no no
no no no no no no no no not at all his
family and a lot of their religious
beliefs
is based on their culture he's from
american samoa his family is
um very traditional uh and and they're
unbelievable people like
so welcoming so great tua works his
ass off because his brother plays for
alabama too right he transferred to
maryland
okay he's gonna play in from mike
locksley he was the former officer
coordinator at alabama
so he's over there so both of you guys
were with two during this documentary
i was so i got to know him and because
of well largely because we were
producing it but also because of corona
like we couldn't leave and go so it was
me and two on the road from
january up until he was drafted in may
on the
define on the road in between living in
nashville he was training with trent
dilfer
trying to get ready he couldn't do the
combine trying to get ready to do a pro
day
and then he was doing his rehab in
alabama back in birmingham with
you know kevin wilke and then those guys
and dr andrews that did all his stuff
so we were kind of like back and forth
between those two places
and at one point when two was started to
progress beyond the injury enough to
where he could start to throw
i i had to catch for him i had to dust
off the uh the mitts
the old mitts now and bro again i'm
pretty sure etcetera
go buffs scopes busker buffs let's go
buffs
these hands no buffs these hands haven't
uh been used to catch footballs
especially from two uh [ __ ] slang
[ __ ]
slings lefty dude yeah oh even more so
at one point at one point i did have to
like downline i'm like dude i think you
broke a ligament in my wrist
because you have to catch all the balls
i was catching yeah winging it but what
he did at one point the most impressive
was
he set up like we set up one of those
target nets like three
holes right here right and this was like
the first week he was cleared to start
throwing like full throwing he was about
45
45 yards away and his goal was to throw
it
over that net but i was back against a
wall
right so he couldn't hit the wall and he
had to clear this net by about
two inches and he hit about like 33 out
of 35
jesus christ which is awesome absolutely
absurd
accuracy he's a freak ball huh and a
tough like cover two hole shot like
very tough throw to make 33 out of 35 is
insane
to do so he would for sure been the
number one pick if he didn't get hurt
dude if he didn't get hurt
yeah i think he's so athletic
and so uh whether they win it or not i
still think he's a no
he would have been the number one pick
but great guy scotty
great dude great dude great family
singer very good singer good karaoke
singer yeah
dude he's uh wines are good at karaoke
and you can see it too with like how the
locker room in miami has
already embraced two and how they talk
about them the guys in alabama like judy
flew out to do his pro day like those
guys loved touah oh wow
and you see a different in the
documentary you see a different side of
tua because he's actually like
two is very funny now alabama i don't
know how much nick allows you to
go up there and be your true self and
then post game interviews raging
[ __ ] actually he was he was pretty
cool man he got to sit down i
interviewed nick for the doc
and he like opened up his home and not
just for his
did you ever see the uh the documentary
hbo did with uh bill and
oh it's saving belichick yeah they're
both
sucking each other off really well
they're like identical disgusting
they're sitting down like dude you're
the grace you're like no you're the
greatest
and they're talking about defense you're
like what the [ __ ] am i watching right
now
this tasty episode talking pigskin with
scotty mcknight
and mark sanchez is brought to you by
on it on it.com fighter 10 off the
entire
goddamn website what do you need man
need protein powder
you need earth grown nutrients you need
shroom tech immune you need alpha brain
to get your mind right krill oil
joint oil we got nutrition we got
fitness gear for your ass
if you're a thicky if you're part of the
thick boy bike club maybe you're getting
sick of riding your bike
and you need to stay in shape how about
you get some kettlebells
how much you get some steel maces battle
ropes just stay
active man on demand training on at six
body weight workouts on on
on at six kettlebell workouts streaming
fitness for your thick ass
they got the [ __ ] yeah coffee it's black
rifle and on it collab
it has freaking caffeinated crystals you
son of a [ __ ]
dark roast extra caffeine get it on
it.com
fighter it's crazy you just have those
drops yeah dude
it's insane though but yeah uh same and
torsion known for just being a raging
[ __ ]
winner though so you you get of like
ellen
winner asked him you know winners yeah i
mean he was he was great he opened up
his house
for like our crew to do the interviews
for him and like two other coaches and
was just like
whatever you guys do crib he makes so
much really cool spot it's an alabama
alabama on the woods he lives right on a
lake again it's alabama though so
yeah i mean does he own olive oil i'm
pretty sure
he's 100 they say the most powerful
people in alabama are
nick saban the starting quarterback at
alabama and then the governor
is the way it makes sense and it's about
it's true like
deep in tua and nick saban alabama
football so
when's the dock drop drops this saturday
september 12th
oh damn on fox yeah and this is the
interesting part with
back with college football is it was
supposed to air right after the
baylor louisiana tech game oh yeah
louisiana tech just had a covet outbreak
now they don't have a football game so
now they're trying to figure out who's
going to schedule that time slot before
maybe two years picks up a game byu's
down they'll they'll play
they'll play any ducks they're robots
though i can call them up right now yep
come get me
come get some messy a lot of those guys
probably watching you when you were uh
on the utah blaze
[Laughter]
like oh shop yes man that's that guy
who's like 280 pounds right you want to
go 300.
yeah byu would take up whatever you got
the i call them scraps
byu scraps i love it i love them man so
you're excited for the doc though
doc will be good i think it shows you
know different side
you've seen this forever like as
athletes you kind of get boxed into this
you know you're behind the helmet or
whatever people don't really know i kind
of wrote him off when his leg fell off
yeah and then he did you see him work
through that entire thing so we're like
in the doctor
the kobe one remember when kobe's like
doing oh yeah
i don't wanna watch it like two hours
long if i'm rehabbing but if it's like
splashed in so it's actually
it's about his whole life so it dates
back to
and i'll give you like the synopsis of
it but his grandfather
took on the tango vailoa his great
grandfather took on the tango valley
last name
had an original last name of afola
because the tango vailoa name they
wanted to lift it to new heights and
their family and american samoa was
known to be prophetic like they could
see the future
so they moved to hawaii and his
grandfather when tua was born
started to prophesy over him that two
was would bring the tango vailoa name
to new heights and it would be known all
over the world because at two you're at
a four four forty and he started
training with his dad when he was like
three little kids yeah they're like on
the beach he's gonna do something cool
footage
yeah there's some really cool stuff and
reenactments and we tell the story and
that's
it doesn't it's not all like ball it's
not all rehab it's like this is
a family that has prayed together that
has rallied together worked together for
years
and you see too it go through the
journey of like him being in
high school and being recruited why he
chose to go to the university of alabama
him stepping in and the night before the
national championship game when he's the
backup to jalen hurts
the night before you he met with his
parents in the hotel and he said
our lives are going to change forever
tomorrow and his parents were like
championships it's not so for the
viewers like jalen hurts was the starter
all season long
baller one interception played like [ __ ]
and then at half time nick saban was
like ah let's give the swine kid a try
and then [ __ ] walk off touchdown wins
the game
but he told his parents the night
transformed
i'm going to change your lives our lives
are going to change and his parents said
don't tell us you're going to change our
lives we want to see it
like that that's the type of i'll tell
you right mom chill yeah so he goes and
does it yeah mom
all right all right well [ __ ] man i got
in my room dad
get out of my room dad i was just saying
i thought maybe tomorrow's gonna be fun
for them there's so much like love and
respect in that family that i think
you get a you get a viewpoint that you
otherwise wouldn't get you get sound
bites you get people trying to make up
you know headlines online of what it but
no that family's like
that's cool you have a girlfriend he
does not
that's a good sign yeah he did tweet out
to shania twain though who i think was
like
his celebrities yeah and she she hit him
back and i'm like sure
all right well maybe shenanigans should
have gone check blue check she's like i
like miami
he's a good singer too so they could do
like a collab together everyone's like
hey dude
uh i we saw you dm shania twain she's
54. so
he's like oh i didn't know that it's
still a babe he's still babe but you
know yeah but he's
he's great dude so that'll be dope man
i'll definitely watch that yeah i'd like
you to
support me i'm your friend appreciate it
at least turn it on and don't change the
channel
yeah dude uh do you have uh college it's
a bit of a [ __ ] show but
as far as nfl goes do you have a
favorite besides the
the betting odds is like chiefs on the
field you didn't take the chiefs or the
field
what were you saying with the texans i
like the saints
i like the saints that division got a
lot tougher i know
but you don't like tampa bay you don't
think brady's gonna figure it out i do
i love tampa and then they got fournette
oh
how about jackson i was like you know
what we're get rid of everybody
i mean i just yeah yeah literally
everybody yeah they're like talking
again okay
you're just gonna tank for trevor
lawrence but they miss on a few guys
they
somebody pulled up their whole draft
record the last night ten years it's
been rough
it's been really rough nightmare yeah
but uh
with with fournette do we know was there
a red flag with them
because it's very strange to let a guy
like that go to me is like oh maybe an
issue in the locker room maybe well i
thought his
can you pull up fournette stuff i i feel
like leonard fournette but i thought
somebody was saying
on the radio talking about how his
numbers the last couple years have been
not great but they don't have anybody
else so they stack the box
and then they run the ball 60 times a
game yeah
the stats yeah
uh 2018 oh he got hurt until 18 right
yes i thought
because he's had two thousand yard
career yeah there you go so as a rookie
rush for a thousand
not great and then last year was a good
year eleven hundred yards four point
three average not a ton of touchdowns
here's what kind of touchdown you look
at like remember uh
who's legarrette blount garrett school
blunt went to the patriots and was like
a major complimentary
power back but and they won a super bowl
what are they gonna do with
lesean mccoy um my guy from sc
sean's whatever was it ronald jones um
they did have like a stud too yeah i
know who you're talking about right now
is the running back
from sc is ronald jones wrong but
mccoy's older man so it's not like he's
gonna be a complimentary but
and also with the with the receivers bro
their receivers are
loaded nuts loaded and i'm not just
saying this because i love
uh you know anyone who's named scotty
but scotty miller
is apparently a dude on the team who's
like 511
slot guy burner oh he's the brady he's
like
white slime he's like he is he is
caucasian american yes
yes uh he's the standard like like right
right time yeah ronald jones is second
round yeah
but this guy brady's like love him so
i'm like
okay dude leonard fournette's their
third string right now
oh you know how it is he'll be there
stable yeah they're stacked but they're
stacked
across the board and they have brady
what worries me is that there's two
stacked
it's always alarming when teams two
stacked yeah remember that when philly
did that they're like we got the dream
team
yeah the thing whenever teams two stacks
lakers with like gary payton and carl
malone it happens
you've seen it a thousand times a
thousand times i feel bad there's like a
right amount of
but i'm rooting for brady because i'm
more of a baby too
i love brady he's like everything right
about being
you know at the top of your game in a
sport his teammates love him he
wins he's competitive he's cool like see
but
to my point that's why i don't think new
orleans is a great there's 14 teams
going
to the playoffs this year yes so only
the first
so one team out of each uh conference
gets a bye instead of the top two so way
more teams two more
teams are making the playoffs so the
seahawks are in the saints are in
the bucks are probably in the packers
the viking like
there's a lot yeah there's there's
opportunities and i don't know i just
like the scenes huh dude it's something
has to come around for them
like they've had these two bs calls the
last two two years that bounced them out
of the playoffs it's like
how long is breeze gonna be able to do
it though this might be his last go
around and watch
when they almost canceled me he's like
hey i think you should stand for the
flag they're all [ __ ]
die whoa i'm drew brees i'm hip
breathing almost got cancelled how crazy
is that yeah that was wild
such a bummer overnight overnight yeah
they are loaded at receiver too if you
look at michael thomas who else did they
got amanda sanders oh that's right yeah
do you think kamara is playing for
another contract that dudes are beat
maybe while we're in here these they're
supposed to sign this contract now how
about dude
yeah oh really yeah he's gonna happen
yeah so they announced this morning
that's what's happening dude
how about [ __ ] uh your boy deshawn
uh watson and uh my home the contract
ridiculous they're ridiculous boys are
getting paid and i think it helps
uh your friend uh dax prescott because
he was like
i'm just gonna wait because what i think
we're so balls deep in football but
people can suck my dick
so what's crazy to me is uh i think
uh jerry jones wanted to get the deal
done with dax before the announcement of
mahomes and uh what uh watson came out
because now
the market that's they they there you go
yeah well if you look you're gonna have
to franchise them twice watch
because next year the market's gonna be
lower because of
just covid and the salary cap could be
lower but
three four five years down the line
these new tv deals are gonna come into
play
nuts dude yeah these salary caps are
going to be insane
so it gives desean watson those first
six years he could be out of that deal
yeah and be ready to get back to the
bank again what were we talking about
wait another six tell shop this we were
looking at the deal in comparison versus
like
their new money the homes is the deal
that like 10 years 503 million you're
like
holy like that's breaking it right yeah
and and
desean came in at like four-year
extension 160 million which doesn't look
as splashy
but if you look at the uh the entirety
of the deal
and you look at the first six years yeah
desean's making more money
those are the first couple years because
let's put over 2020
watson 27 million mahomes over 8 million
watson wait how much 27 million this
year watson mahomes is making eight
million
new money oh wow money but hold on
before you read that what but what was
the guarantee to mahomes
i thought it was the highest guarantee
uh because it's the longest
oh so that makes sense yeah oh so you
still it's not like baseball or
basketball where you get the money no
matter what
you start on the team oh wow right and
they have a good rollover clause after
all these years for mahomes basically
saying like
if he gets cam newton yeah that year
that next year is guaranteed with an
offset clause from a new team
so damn if we owed you 20 and we cut
your ass
boom now you go to buffalo well
buffalo's gonna pay you 5 million so
that takes out of that
20 that we owe you we owe you 15 they're
gonna pay that five but you're getting
that 20. oh
interesting yeah which is yeah so really
[Music]
but these first couple years are insane
so 27 million
to eight in 2020 2021 is 20 million to
six
jesus christ what's in over my home
actually my home's deal is not that
great especially
it is it's all it's just but then you've
got to look at it like 10 years
does desean watson want to marry himself
to bill o'brien in the texas
as much as uh patrick mahomes wants to
marry himself to andy reed who she loves
andy reed's had like two or three losing
seasons in a 20-something year career
he signed travis kelsey yeah like he's
just like tyreek hill yeah like he's
loaded and he's a team guy who's just i
don't even think of that
i think i think mahomes just balled out
that's nuts
so they're both spectacular players
mahomes just has the super bowl and the
mvp right now
so i think it's going to actually help
prescott though down the road because
i think they said last year he made 2
million right this shitty deal
this year he's going to make something
like 30 something million yeah he'll
make that next year
so they said over the three seasons
they're going to end up paying them 90
something million dollars oh yeah if
they don't give them the long term yeah
it's essentially like a kirk cousins
deal would he just signed in minnesota
it's very simple good for him man yeah
it's great he deserves it he's playing
his [ __ ] then hopkins
got paid too he got paid but he
negotiated his own deal yeah
isn't that weird when guys do it but so
did so did your boy uh sherman
yeah i know sherman did russell kung did
yeah russell kung did you can you know
there's a lot of fine print in there i
mean
i i personally wouldn't want to do that
but those guys you know
kudos to them so you don't recognize
that they're like that's why you have
lawyers
yeah yeah i don't know i think i i read
something today and i don't know how
accurate it was but like
his last deal is not like they can get
out a bit or something like his last
year of that deal
i don't know he's a he's a hell of a
player i mean obviously
i'd imagine they're going to want to
keep him there especially in that kind
of offense like
tyler murray yeah kylo ren he's like
i think mvp i still think they're third
or fourth in the division
uh you have niners teams and seahawks
they're good and the rams who they're
not bad either
rams are right they're all right all
right any team without
aaron donald is a he's he's a beast i
think they're broke
he played golf in a little bit of a
tricky situation maybe but
i mean they're still like they're not
jacksonville
no you know what i mean like their coach
is great
so okay i like him yeah like you're
gonna be in decent positions you might
you'll have certain players at certain
positions that are just better than
other teams
i'd still rather be the cardinals i
don't know
we can make it better right now that the
cardinals don't finish better than
fourth
like how do you want to bet that the
cardinals have a better season than the
rams
the cardinals have to finish fourth no
they just have to have a better season
than rams
when more yeah then they would finish
better than fourth yeah
let me talk to my i don't want to
negotiate my own contract okay
okay i'll talk to my agent all right all
right i'll talk to you after the show
all right cool
yeah i feel like it's a good bet for me
the rams got to win more games let's
look at their schedules right now then
do it man
we will help bring their schedules up
chin
well because because in conference can
be scrappy man because you've got
seattle yeah the niners good luck with
that
if either teams with the niners or or
seahawks okay so cowboys that's a tough
game you guys losing that one
uh eagles definitely losing that one
bills they're [ __ ] good
giants you'll win that one washington
you win that one rams
losing that one well no they are the
rams they are the rounds i'm sorry
niners under squad scrimmage
lost inner squad floss the bucks
you guys got a tough schedule dude bears
you win dolphins you win seahawks loss
bucks loss niners lost cardinals lost
are they side by side how does this work
boom boom boom boom boom that's a weird
way they did it patriots who knows
you think cam newton's gonna dude that
i'm so curious about that
the rumblings we hear at like everyone's
so cute everybody loves them
i guess belichick was like dude nobody
works harder
his arm's great like he's driven he's
determined he's got something to prove
chip on his shoulder all that stuff i
just don't have a lot of tools
yeah yeah who was brady throwing to last
year you know it's just
they gotta hope to kill harry stays
healthy right the first round guy out of
arizona state a couple years ago oh
that's right he was a stud
sony michelle like they're not you're
gonna find out if
is the belch system or if it was
dude how great is it that gronk retires
though
brady leaves and gronk comes back
convinced them oh yeah and they're in fl
it's just unbelievable like the two of
them back together
he said gronk's looking healthy yeah
dude a couple of the mic'd up episodes
of him
on nfl or whatever it's on oh nfl live
or whatever he's freaking hilarious
like he is like he's like exhausted he's
such a frat boy but he's exhausted and
he's like
trying to talk himself into like
finishing the practice like we're gonna
make it man to uh
their other tight end mayo he's like
yeah we got this
a couple more routes it's hot out here
though you kind of
hear him like wavering you know and he's
like but you know we're going to do it
we're going to do it yeah yeah
and then he goes and like catches the
pass he's like still got it here we go
here we go
hey would have blown you up huh or you
would have blown me up either way that
sucks
all right next play like he's just like
dude he's so stupid
it's so much fun it's so cool so much
fun
loves it god he's funny yeah i'm gonna
take that bet with the cardinals
yeah dude what a stupid best scottie why
did you bet that huh
what so what is in the bed uh
rams over cardinals who has a better
record yeah
um i think i'm a kyle murray taking the
ram yeah i'm taking the rams too dude
wow you don't like uh
the cardinals operation i do i just
i'm taking the rams all right kevin
o'connell's back there kevin o'connell
yeah i'm taking that bet right now
take it what is the bet i don't know if
not the french recommend
better record yeah better record okay
so i'm taking the rams so for those who
don't know we actually uh
me mark and kevin o'connell the
offensive coordinator for the rams
uh we actually tp nick mangold's house
while we all played together
he had an infant and it was on
thanksgiving and his family was all
there
were they pissed oh dude we didn't tell
him this was 2012. we didn't
we told him eight years later just told
him on the podcast a week ago what do
you say
he said he wasn't happy
i almost forgot about that but i was
really pissed and we were like
sorry all right man thanks for coming on
we were planning on
telling him at the time yeah oh so we go
to pick him up the next morning
this one you guys are all playing for
the jets yes he goes can you believe
this [ __ ]
i think these giants kids down the
street these fans
they they did this oh hey dude look at
how hot
like we threw it up and you gotta figure
out what this is
mark sanchez threw it up there so we
were like
oh no like this is bad he's actually mad
he goes i got my son here like my
newborn baby my
uh in-laws are all here everybody's like
picking up stuff we were doing like
that'd be so mad thanksgiving
pre-christmas stuff all this kind of
stuff going on and we're just like ooh
this was bad so i literally look in the
rearview mirror to see scotty in the
back seat as he's getting in the thing
and i'm like
don't tell him well he always do that he
also did it
dude i'm sorry he said something he goes
i mean look how high it is like
were these guys like water pool players
or what when we're like
throwers or something you don't think
one maybe played quarterback at
sc to get it up there nick two nfl
quarterbacks was he pissed and i kind of
got a hose too
you got you and i have a good arm yeah
good arm figure it out
how's the show going fourth and forever
fourth and forever baby how's it going
you guys knocking it out
yeah we had demarcus ware on he was
great great uh marquis lee
who opted out of the season had to got
traded to the patriots
and opted out why he said he's got his
kid at home
newborn newborn wife really really
interesting story too because he grew up
two deaf parents orphanages like foster
homes throughout l.a
and he's like i had a kid like that's my
main thing i want to be there good for
him
yeah it was some good stuff yeah and he
talked about going to belichick and just
saying like hey like
i can't i bet belichick was just like oh
he said he was
listen i respect your decision i have
kids as well i don't know what i do in
that situation
and see you next year that's all you can
really do yeah i mean
just great was [ __ ] chris long yeah
chris long i like chris long
he's really good have you had him on
yours no yeah you guys would be great is
he in la
uh he's in virginia yeah virginia
okay well it's gonna be tough well well
you can we don't really do
on this show we don't do skype do you
guys do holograms yet hologram guest
uh you've had michael jackson on okay
yeah cool that must have been an
interesting interview
uh yeah i love chris long though he's
great he was good on there he's
awesome he's a sharp guy his family's
the best i lived with his brother kyle
oh did you really inch in chicago yeah
that's right yeah the cow's great too
kyle's favorite bunch of studs oh yeah
it's just a factory
unbelievable it's them and then who what
uh
the bosses they're saying actually
that's what i asked
you guys in a cage match you the two
bosses and youtube what do you think
because you're a fighter
[ __ ] uh man i'm gonna take the bosus
really i think so
i'm too sorry you might have to kill
kyle i
like actually kill him nick he's like a
zombie such a monster yeah i know
they're both who's better players
well i mean kyle plays offensive line
yeah i know
there's pro balls and those other guys
are two d-liners i don't know
pro balls that that's what i'm thinking
if they're all
such studs man do you bring their dads
in though it's like the celebrity guests
and it's three on here's the prom
the the longs win because their dad's a
hall of famer dude
yeah howie flat top they call him flat
tires come on flat top
oh [ __ ] classic i'm like this is a
flat top how much money do you think
they'd make if they did
a long brothers boso brothers cage
fight in the off season i don't think
much why
she can't fight you don't think they can
you don't think people like nfl fans
would be like i'm going to watch the
bowser brothers or or maybe not a fight
but like some sort of decathlon
like an election like a ninja warrior
kind of like that
i'm not into it you wouldn't watch it
yeah 49.99
huh 39. well because our both are both
six topics are both the lungs retired
yeah
yeah it's a tough sell now if they're
both like rookies and like
you got a group of four and they're both
coming in like maybe but one's retired
and the other two are
just getting started i got it so you're
big on discrimination
yeah so i was told age is just a number
but
it's not it's real well shania twain
didn't think so yeah
you have something to say about that
yeah doesn't care uh go to current
events jim sure
oh dear oh dear oh dear what do we got
you know what we have
oh no i [ __ ] hate coming
i [ __ ] hate california
[Music]
yeah can you cancel it yeah you can dude
you can make it illegal to
this is great this is not okay rumor
has it that odell beckham likes to get
[ __ ] on
and this came from the same girl who
came on that podcast and talked to steve
about the suns like when the girls
talked about like blowing seven of the
sun's players
in the hotel room at once yeah have you
heard no chasers no jumper podcasts
no girls just like oh yeah i sucked off
all the seven players on the suns
at the same time like one after the
other oh okay
no she didn't yeah come on yeah like she
came on podcast
and her friend was the guest brought her
on and she told this crazy story they
ended up getting their own podcast
as a spin-off from that main one which i
think is on barstool
they had a guest on and the guest is uh
rapper chief keef's
um baby mama she came on said that she
spent some time with eldell beckham jr
and that he wanted her to record herself
pooping and send it to him i'm not
buying him i don't buy that because
here's the line because here's the thing
so this is just there's no evidence no
of course no
there's no evidence but here's the
problem so this no jumper podcast they
come out
they slim danger great name but slim
danger but so
like weeks ago they come out with she
sucked off seven of the suns and it goes
super viral right
like right that's cool so how so how can
they follow
that's cool how can they follow that up
you know
so then they so then slim danger slim
danger comes out
and also odell's about one upper you
know
it's just ratings and also otto beckham
handsome dude how's his pick of the
litter
yeah i'm not saying slim danger isn't
attractive but
she's not beckham attractive let's be
real here
it just doesn't it's too much smoke
there's too much smoke
danger's on the right is she the sun's
mvp is that her
no the sun's mvp is the one on the left
is the one
in the yeah back left uh should we play
it was she wearing a mask
sure which one yeah
i think this was before covid to be fair
okay you gotta do it
are they doing this outside like a fifth
grade pe class what's that
chain link fence okay i don't know the
longevity of this show
okay that was my first time ever i never
did it
you actually no i i actually couldn't
[ __ ] okay see i'm not buying it
we gotta get [ __ ] on the way here what
the [ __ ] i could not do it that was
something like i'm a wife
i could do some freak [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
i'm saying but the [ __ ]
you can't just do that to me like on the
spot watch like [ __ ] right now
okay he wanted me to come on a plane and
he was like make sure you don't have any
underwear don't take a shower for 24
hours i'm like damn what the [ __ ] you
want
but he was like take a picture this how
i got flown out he was like take a
picture of me you shouldn't so i was
like all right [ __ ] i can do that
so you just do that what you want i
love you take a video so i sent it to
him i got
like the next maybe two hours i was wow
in here was it like a selfie video
how did you do this i was just i need
that i need lessons
[ __ ] just like i made it sexy as
possible
of of course so much for girls not
pooping
they do i i i'm just not buying it i
don't buy it at all
but also how long is that podcast can
you imagine listen to the rest of that
oh man where does he go here's the deal
you can't do that and there's no
evidence
of it at this point like this day and
age if you're sending videos and then
calling someone out on a podcast
there's a recorded correspondence
there's no repercussions for like
you're just slandering the man's name
yeah it's not cool
it's just not cool and everyone look the
people that i know o'dell that are like
friends with him are like he's awesome
like he's a really
cool dude and like i just think you know
that's the problem is someone can come
on
say something absurd that probably
absolutely ridiculous
and there's no proof to it and then
that's going to be run with that
so are we gonna take slim dangers word
here this is so well i'm not for the
record
i'm not taking her word i am not yeah
i'm going down arrow on that yeah
the hard down arrow i'm a uh odell
beckham jr fan such a [ __ ] talent too
he's a baller oh dude and he's like he's
changed the game i think he's the most
followed
nfl player like in the league he's great
social
i love him i don't think he's got great
dance moves too
he's good at everything great his hair
it's a great style yeah
he didn't work out very popular i'm a
fan what else she got i don't believe
slim danger
i've also never heard the name slim
danger before this but whatever
and this is the one you guys hated l.a
county has said that they're canceling
halloween by
not allowing people to trick-or-treat
have parties carnivals
the whole nine and what is the fun
what's the uh
what happens if you don't know what's
gonna happen can you dress up in your
own home
i think that might be okay but you might
get your water shut off
wow no way did you hear about the tick
tockers they got
they threw a huge party in the hollywood
hills and a couple days later they had
their power and water shut off
yeah for i think close to a week
you can do that uh the mayor of l.a did
it i don't know if he could but he did
it he did
it it's insane it's not working has lost
his goddamn mind i don't hate anybody on
this earth
but i would suck newsome in the day that
would hurt his dick
because you suck really hard real hard
sock yeah
might explode i hope some danger shits
on knew some i can't stand them
you cancel halloween it's my kids
favorite holiday dude yeah what would
you what would you dress up that's just
in l.a county you can go out to like
riverside and
i'm i'm sure orange county orange county
like halloween's popping off down there
i can't i gotta drive an hour with my
kid i could wear the [ __ ] suit before
you can come hang out with us we don't
need it we're good
we'll all be in suits also halloween
everyone's a mask anyways
that's true that's really worried about
it and kids can't spread it's a [ __ ]
that's a weird hallway for the holiday
for them to cancel then it's the
one where people wear masks how about i
bet christmas is next
christmas you can't get anyone having
christmas at their house we're going to
cut off their water
[Music]
way to ruin the day i'm sorry i just
needed you to know before you got your
water shut off yeah i'm wario for
halloween though my son's mario
admitted to masturbate so uh joe budden
has gotten in a lot of trouble recently
for some domestic violence stuff but
this actually popped off because there's
footage of him admitting to
previously jacking off his dog to make
the animal happy this is joe biden what
joe buddy nobody
but biden probably also i'm just saying
this is from his podcast i'm sorry it's
a girl
we're just using slurs don't worry about
it why do i always want to make the dog
feel good by playing with the [ __ ]
privates
how about his friends he's paying to be
on the show
anybody with a pet you come on you did a
little something down there man made
your dog feel good
no here's the deal classic case of being
too high
you're right classic you're right he's
too high he thought everyone's fighting
with it he's like
y'all don't jack off your dogs
this is real weird bro he's all [ __ ]
y'all dude
and look you have to double down on it
too it's awful
oh god how great for the dog though
i don't i don't know you don't know
that dog's probably just like dude some
of these tweets are
so funny dude the internet is undefeated
though with a lot of this stuff
hey yo scroll up what's that folks so
joe wouldn't really say anybody with a
pet come on you did a little something
down there to make dog feel good
that guy go that's a filthy sick [ __ ]
why would you say
why would he say that i've never heard
of that dude i love when you've never
i've never heard that you look at people
that'll like leave comments and they're
like
you know [ __ ] you that just total troll
like
[ __ ] and you'll go to their page
and it's like you know praise god
oh yeah like your hands i'm like it's
the worst what
the worst dude that's bad that's
hilarious also joe budden what the [ __ ]
dude
what else you got all right so there was
a documentary i guess it was just
released about michael jackson
it's the other one oh what's it on so
it's the it's like another app
i'm not sure that would be good but it's
uh the the detective's in charge of
you know investigating his death so they
have pictures of his room
and that's what he had like a life like
porcelain or a baby
plastic doll or something like that is
that a jaguar uh gaming system
i don't know what is that jaguar
gamecube dude is it really fun
it's a dreamcast a player it's a cd
player that's an old-school cd when did
he die
oh is that the 2009 player you can learn
spanish
guys he was learning another language he
died in 2009
and he was learning how to puppeteer
yeah what's happening baby
that's what happened to people but all
he had was a stuffed baby no no there's
also pictures of like
babies in like like magazine cutouts oh
look
dude look at the weird kid oh yeah
posters of them he makes it tough to
defend him
he makes it tough to defend him that's a
weird one that is
and then they said didn't they find like
pictures of kids too like a whole
catalog pictures of kids so what do you
call that there's just a bunch of like
baby pictures
shrine yeah the problem is i don't
really know how to break that down
go back one picture like i think that's
a good thing what's all this yeah right
so he had like medication scattered
around everywhere he had an iv
bag around his shower i read a little
bit about this they said the doctor they
he should have got second degree
manslaughter because what the way he
killed him they're like dude he had
enough
uh whatever they gave her enough to kill
a problem
and i think what's whatever xanax is
yeah i think it was and but the problem
is is that he also i think tried to like
just like get rid of something oh no so
what they said is
instead of in real he they realized he
realized michael jackson
was not breathing of getting him cpr he
went and hit everything and
hit it first and then came back and
called the cop oh that's fine like why
wouldn't you
try to give the guy cpr if you stop
breathing why would you hide this stuff
first so
they're pissed he only he got four years
he only did two
yeah is the doctor on this documentary i
didn't see the doc but i don't think
he's like
it's just that three main cops
investigating so that's just weird stuff
around us
i don't know it's it's weird like it's
just baby pictures insane
it's not good they said he was healthy
for a 50 year old man too that's what's
strange
that's weird it's just a tough girl
tough too did you watch the first dock
i did that was tough to watch
that's just uncomfortable because you
grow up like
idolizing someone like that or just like
standing right lies them not idolizing
but you wear from the jump but yeah
you know we're gonna have to cut that
out did he grow up
you grow up uh listening to his music
he grew up listening to his music i
liked his music and we all liked to like
beat it
yeah it's just like man in the mirror
celebrating the whole catalogue
does joe didn't like that song beat it
he loves it you know
folsom uh any time i caught a ball my
junior year they played thriller by
michael jackson
yeah i regretted that one when i saw a
documentary i regret every catch i uh
yeah it's uh that that i could go back
i'd drop them all yeah i would drop
those balls
that documentary is a little weird
because one of the
it's tough to say you don't believe him
but also i don't really believe those
guys
like the the one main guy do you know
that just
two years prior to that documentary
coming out he went to the family because
michael jackson would do something in
las vegas they're gonna do a jack show
he's like oh let me be the choreographer
and do all this stuff and like no we're
good dude
and then he came out after that yeah so
it's like i don't i don't know dude
the only thing yeah it's tough what to
believe it's tough because you don't
really
it's it's like like the only people that
really know or the
people who are there and they have their
version of their truth right
did you see that they're just on show
time
out cry on show do we have them on the
show oh my god that
that dog blew my mind i'm on the show
have you seen it it's it's incredible
nuts because like the first stop
railroaded this dude a hundred the
second we're like oh man this isn't cool
and my third one like oh my god what are
we gonna do what are we doing here
the dock space has gotten great like
that that kind of stuff too outcry is so
[ __ ] good
it's i think the best doc i've seen this
yeah it's so good to see that yeah yeah
i think he's in new york living with his
girl not playing for the
he was supposed to play for texas she
gave up that dream
did he and when i found he gave up
decided not to have him on the show oh
so he's not coming on the show he's not
just kidding that's not what i'm gonna
have on the show but he did give up
which bumps me out
he's going through he's gone through a
lot he's gone through a shitload i'd see
if you don't want to play
oh you don't want to be a walking at
texas like it's a tough go dude
yeah yeah you got to watch the dock it's
nuts dude
brian daley brian daly show time he did
it
yeah it's show time wow stephen
neema ghazi you know nema you know the
squad squad
damn the crew son come on doug do you
guys know who caster simenia is
never heard of him it's a female that's
interesting you that you said that she's
a female she's trying to be funny
long distance that's like a middle
distance runner uh she's a gold medalist
and she wants to defend her tie
or her record for in the tokyo olympics
but she has to
she has to do something where it drops
her hormones because she has too
high of testosterone levels but just
naturally
that's the way god made her man yeah
it's not fair so they so then you give
her like more estrogen to lower
something like that yeah that's slower
even with the other
that's but that's not the way she was
born that's so stupid that's like
that's so that's also athletes are built
differently in
every sport like you can't start to
regulate how many
many levels of things do we know how
high like serena williams testosterone
is it's like
where does this i'm sure a lot of women
that are dominant figures in sports have
high testosterone this is a weird one
though is hers like through the roof is
she like unsworn your testosterone
so she has a sexual disorder of
both x and y chromosomes so she has male
stuff in her wait what
do you know this woman right here she
she's obviously like kind of part
sort of woman and man but mostly woman
to have me chin i'm not a doctor
wait so does she have uh says both x and
y
chromosomes wait a second organization
i don't know she has testicles athletes
who have a disorder of sexual
development and have
both x and y chromosomes the standard
male pattern
would have to lower their testosterone
levels to keep competing in women
now let me ask you this hey dr chin let
me ask you this yes yes
so let's say a girl got bronze and they
tested her levels and she was lower
can she take testosterone to get to the
girl who got
gold no that's a good point it's
ridiculous it's [ __ ] stupid
well i think they just put a threshold
on it right like yeah but can i hit that
threshold can i take artificial
testosterone
oh so we're all at the same threshold if
you're gonna lower hers
which by the grace of god he gave her a
high testosterone and she's just this
beast of a runner you know it's an
interesting argument and
and would be fun if anyone would ever
let it happen is like let just let
everyone take whatever they want oh
that's the way it should be and just
compete it kind of
crazy yeah i can't understand this
is she just dominating yeah
i mean she does look also i mean we all
can tell right she looks i think that's
just you jim
yeah i'm not seeing that i don't see it
don't speak um for that comment all
right
all right let's see
yeah i don't get what's wrong all right
never mind
nothing wrong at all he retracts his
statement
she's she's pretty jacked she's project
yeah that's crazy man yeah that's that's
not right it's not right
so she's not going to do it even though
that would be her way then she's not
going to run she she can't compete in
the game
yeah unless she kills so that was her
appeal right now but the court said no
you can't
so she would have to take that stuff
then take it no
she's she's standing up for her that's
great n-y-a
well good for her
what else oh okay so this one
all right dang remember this uh taco
bell got rid of a lot of menu items
oh yeah what's going on with that why
did they do that unless a lot of people
talk about this
what did they get rid of well here's the
list there it is all this
the seven-layer burrito supremes are
gone this happened in august
but they recently have been there in a
while they're getting rid of the mexican
pizza now
and that's going to go away in november
and that was that was my favorite thing
too i love you mexico dude
if you want to [ __ ] your pants order
mexican pizza so good though oof
do you know why they're getting rid of
it what's the crunchyroll supreme though
that's still
let's see they still doing stuff with
the dorito
shell yep yeah i love those oh i heard
those are going away too
okay what they say about the mexican
pizzas good the boxes are taking too
much you know it's
too much trash all the all the the paper
the paper for the boxes yeah it's not
these environments
make them out of a different material
maybe yeah what about a different
material i don't know
real soft taco okay similar burrito not
supreme one of my faves i like those
uh i like those the spicy potatoes no
don't care
cheesy fiesta potatoes staple um
i'm not familiar familiar with the
loaded griller it is the cheesy potato
loaded griller is top notch
i never had that i'm nacho supreme are
you [ __ ]
chips and pico de gallo yeah they get
rid of pico de gallo
but can i still get the chips and the
nacho cheese
that's wild i'm sure you could because
cheese is very important
wow i love as long as i got crunchwrap
supremes those yeah
do you pretty healthy how you [ __ ]
uh i don't eat fast food as much
but i do like it does your kid eat
healthy
yeah he does pretty well he eats
everything yeah so has he had
food though uh like mickey do you know
we've had chick-fil-a i've never taken
them to mcdonald's
oh i know i just i don't know
i know but it's just so i'd rather take
him to chick-fil-a
teach itself i got him a ceiling fan for
his birthday too
the doritos cool ranch and fiery doritos
those are going to be gone
wow wow unreal man oh [ __ ] the grilled
stuffed burrito
double decker taco god i love the double
deck are you
kidding me [ __ ] me that was it
[ __ ] that was the struggle
dude [ __ ] out man i'm a del taco guy
now the double decker's my
favorite thing how do you get rid of
like it who is in that board meeting
oh yeah that guy should be [ __ ] fired
immediately who said double decker get
the [ __ ] out
now because here's the thing you got the
soft taco you got the crunchy taco
you got the supplies sandwich them
together dude
[ __ ] you taco bell how about that man
lost my business
you lost my business don't say it yeah
actually we could maybe use their
sponsorship so taco bell hey whatever
you guys think is is appropriate
i'm out man crunchwrap supreme bring
back the double
that doesn't even make sense then so
these are the new combos
and they have a mexican pizza here too
yeah what i don't know what's going on
misinformation oh they rank these are
ranked oh they're ranked
new combos
anyhow i like it chicken quesadilla man
oh they're chicken quesadillas so good
with the jalapeno sauce it's so good
taco bell is really good
[Applause]
the fourth meal was huge fourth meal
yeah they invented that
chihuahua yeah it's a lot i'm more of a
del taco fan though i like their uh
uh hot sauce better their cheeseburger
double double
cheeseburger their cheeseburger is fire
and everyone's so good
yeah you're gonna get a hard time here
too what dude
yeah dude hey you gotta you gotta
dealt are you go to delta and order a
burger i know
have you ever had it that's really good
i'm not good because i only like the i
only like the soft chicken tacos
those are good too really good mouth is
water and fat
yeah try both of them yeah i'm gonna do
that well
guys we love you i'm gonna get taco bell
same thing and before they take away all
those things oh november
we have until november yeah november 5th
or 9th we can go on halloween and
celebrate
oh uh scotty can check out your doc
saturday but we don't know when saturday
9 12 at 1 p.m pacific
4 p.m eastern you're just hoping that a
big game before
yeah with all the scraps up call my boy
byu cougars go cougars
let's do it they're going to play utah
blaze it's going to be bananas
come back there you go and then for you
dude obviously uh i watch you on youtube
fourth and forever fourth of forever
abc's uh saturday football game start
this week
all right don't brag let's do this
you're killing it we got uh
what do we got clemson and wake forest
and
georgia tech florida state damn good
games that's the saturday mm-hmm
abc baby and then you're flying back up
to
bristol bristol espn to do the to do
that get up and and saturday oh you get
up all day be able to do from home
on friday so after the thursday night
game which is great so we'll talk
chiefs texans this friday be good
love it thank you guys man love both you
guys love you too
appreciate you man